Carrie Underwood breaks down in tears  during her emotional tribute to the Las  Vegas shooting victims this has been a  year marked by tragedy impacting  countless lives including so many in our  country music family so tonight we're  gonna do what families do come together  pray together cry together and sing  together to carry delivered a touching  in memoriam performance during  Wednesday's CMAs  [Music]  but the singer got a bit choked up when  she honored the victims of the route 91  music festival shooting in Las Vegas in  October he's calling  [Music]  it wasn't the only moving tribute of the  night Eric Church opened the show  singing Amazing Grace followed by a  stage full of country stars performing  the classic Hootie and the Blowfish hit  hold my hand  [Music]  you